this is our first viewing event he'll
see my first viewing on my first view
you seen them before
I've seen the open I swore I was never
gonna sit through it again I've seen the
opening I've seen the ending the opening
was really boring the first 10 minutes
of this movie it's actually really great
yeah like I remember that great to me I
got the soundtrack soundtrack so yeah no
sorry it'll be nice to finally see what
a lot of the music went to because I
love them you know the soundtracks
feeling good thing about it 2 hours long
as fuck nice for first viewing his
second Van Helsing who is this part of
the dark universe that's sad when this
is a better dark universe see that's my
jam I love this shit I love the stuff in
the music this this part is great oh it
does kind of look like a Count Chocula
commercial Betty drop the scalding hot
tomatoes got them I just love this guy
like I so wanted more sauce try on right
here I'm just like Oh Rinna's sam raimi
movie's gonna be great in the dark of
the night evil will find her
how much fun must it be to play
Dracula's livesey yeah cuz that's all
you ever do always the same thing it's
harlot or whore but like super
over-the-top
it's like silent film acting somebody
spills snot on the oh no it's in color
now okay this is the music you hear in
your uncharted game and you land in a
new exotic city you know he doesn't look
the least bit real but he looked cool
you know the director it's just like is
that an amazing it really looks like
he's there it's like no no it doesn't
but it looks cool yeah let's have these
quiet suspenseful moments cuz I don't
know if he's gonna make it out or not
Batman's fighting the Joker are you
[Laughter]
really that's the best you could go I'll
bet that's upsetting yeah come on
unarmed there's so many more than bad
jokes you can put there you're not
beneath bad jokes I see you went out on
a limb every time this guy gets a roll
you know it's like no can I be really
silly with a goofy accent of course look
into my eyes because they will pop out
of my skull and attack you confess
confess Wolverine Origins watch it and
you know it on his daughter princess on
a team is time period that is a guy we
are very feminine mayor's now
double-oh-seven your latest design a pen
you click it twice it explodes this is
my latest invention I was just kidding
is that really what we're doing this is
literally Fifty Shades of Grey is there
no colour in this movie
I am from Soul Calibur - yeah you just
want like little character the bottom
I'll choose my own destiny fight okay
that that's just a boat
no it's still cool gentlemen you will
now be disarmed to some I totally sure
told hide that you know what like days
later you think of a good comeback and
it's like oh oh but designs are all cool
like they look cool the werewolf look
cool I mean where are their nipples
fucking pg-13 come on you Fantasia gave
us nipples how long have they actually
just sat and had a conversations oh I
mean it's like something's always moving
something's always trying to attack the
scuffle moving yeah like a fucking movie
is like this I'd like the action just is
like kind of meaningless yeah I'm so
afraid something's gonna have these
characters that I barely fucking know
that was like what's that ninja turtle
magic
don't play coy with me princess princess
her mother is queen of a dumb what's
that gonna do they're gonna go to hell
anyway so what does that welcome to the
haunted man Disney will not be
responsible for items to the moons I
[Music]
missed you are we in color now so I
noticed so anytime a woman in a movie
says I can handle this myself it's like
okay when does she get captured captured
killed yeah I can handle this nice yeah
yeah I'll be later yeah that cave is so
ridiculous I kind of love it it's like a
cane Ichi and Scratchy whenever I drink
the bodies down there wait a minute the
castle has a bomb medieval times maybe
he does a TGI Fridays in the basement
well haven't really scared some computer
thing is gonna pop out that's not really
there I'm an interpretive dance wall
fabulous I like I like that ripping the
skin off that's a cool idea yeah I'm
glad I saved you after drugging you and
leaving you in bed alone for your own
protection
that was some bad dubbing
no what do you get when your director is
done getting a fill that makes you feel
really no magic why didn't you just try
Sam Raimi to see it could be fighter man
3 every time they do that a lot though
just laying flat yeah it's not a
question of where grips it it's a matter
of weight ratio 5 Pat cannot carry a 130
pound helmet
how long has it been 3 400 years don't
we man what do you that wonderful night
impossible you me oh I did your hair you
did any second he's resting fish face
just take this scene and just replace it
with bubble South a dart gun takes down
the Frankenstein monster no you heard
what he said
I can sense evil this thing evil does
not rule it really so you killed Jekyll
and cold blood this guy will bring about
the doom of the universe no I can't cuz
it's not really evil was Jekyll really
yeah like that was Hyde and then the
painting came live at the to preach is a
tech teacher he's like the weenie
Emperor gold gold use your passive
aggressive feelings boy
longest cliff ever it's it there's still
that evil I can't point out so suspense
Levin if they're really on that clip
that the carrots is really on fire those
horses early that it's all really
happening it's so exciting and I like
all of them I really don't want anything
to happen to it this sounds on every
level hey that's not fair I don't want
the forces to die okay the fire what do
you want I don't know
this meandering way sway your master
will be less inclined to expose his his
other side so he kissed a guy once you
know what it's okay this was going to be
my original costume they thought it was
too serious though you won't turn into a
werewolf and to the writing of your
first full moon that's two nights from
now even then you'll still be able to
fight regulars oh shut up
oh my god then this thing's gonna happen
based on this thing that hurts a Hanzo
will somebody shut the professor up
scene where it's like I feel opportunity
wasted cuz I'm like man Dracula throwing
a big party something this is bad but I
kind of want something more interesting
yeah for everything else we're seeing
house just isn't bad but man this is
getting crazy yeah people drink wine
yeah bathing in blood they do we get
those crazy shirt Britain dance no wake
up I hated those earrings the earrings
they were drugged
they only reside you like the party
seize the only part the movie then has
any fucking color yeah
what's yeah we fell apart
oh no we have to save the Frankenstein
monster cuz again we made such a
connection with him not our friend
Frankenstein monster TV gimmick name how
could it be they gave him a name I think
it's like fuck so basically in
screenwriting it's the important
question is not what it's why yeah and
all they're saying is what we see movies
where they do too much lie to the matrix
does that yeah will the meet all it for
a while that's the food yeah that's the
flip where that's too much why not
enough
the father didn't have this where did
you get this I can't remember the movies
is that boring
please forget where you got that wrong
seize a chair you on the other side huh
I have you now carebears
really just like a Care Bears yeah this
whole place just seems like cold hearts
portraits the Care Bears meet Dracula oh
my god I saw I see that you'd be better
than this remembered Blade 2 when they
actually had the mouths open up like
they actually made those things that was
stupid oh yeah no he's really falling
that's really him
good oh he's really hanging there yeah
yeah oh my god it's so exciting and oh
no what we'll really him there do this
is bother you I'm not touching you
what's this the Frankenstein monster
story ends in tragedy did not see that
coming you look at me ceiling talk to
you man just walking around your house
like that
today I feel I would like some McDonald
Frankenstein monster kinda got hosed
it's really socks I wish I was on fire
what Frankenstein movie answer you know
what the sea is calling to be let me go
there so thanks for not saving us my
entire family's dead and we're all up
here now thank you
yeah go van Helsing fight they're
literally no monsters left well IIIi
have said my piece so many times about
this movie in my life about how much I
fucking ate it I'll let you go you might
be angry it's not as bad as I thought it
would be because
because of Dracula and Frankenstein
Mountains know it that that's where here
in huge dark man on the screen right now
keep adding there and these two clods
it keeps acting like what they have is a
serious movie when they're on screen and
it's clearly not and they're boring and
they're horribly written and they really
aren't just action figures yeah and
that's it's so boring because they the
two main characters are so brain I keep
forgetting there's even a brother as the
werewolf because he just disappears and
they spank and they survive that's
supposed to be like the emotional arc
and it's like who gives a shit yeah
there it is not good the monsters are a
little fun but yeah it's boring dog dumb
don't just don't don't don't don't do
van Helsing don't let me lend you a hand
Spock
[Laughter]
you